goosebumps every time I need that
to desire
what is up guys I'm be showing you a
great guy to use a cannon and train your
melee while also making money the only
requirements is you have to complete the
Femina kyle's and then I also recommend
having a decent prayer level you need to
have at least 43 and then having some
decent stats for melee I have about
average stats for melee 7077 d but
that'll work and then also the gear you
need you need to have the feminine
shield and then the year I'm using I
would just suggest using your best
prayer / high defense armor so I'm using
some couple prayer items that also have
defense and then I'm also using the
Berserker ring and then I don't have
barrows gloves but I would recommend
barrows clothes instead and then this is
kind of what your setup should look like
have a bunch of cannon balls to have a
spec weapon have your cannon have a
bunch of prayer pots because you will be
praying melee have some strength and
attack bonuses to use for your potions
and then bring a stamina potion for the
way I'm going there but basically the
way I'm going to get there I'm gonna go
through relic ax
because my home is at relic R so then
I'm just gonna go ahead and speed this
up so when I get to where I need to go
all right so once you get here you're
going to want to travel to
JT's oh
and then you will take you there
and
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be killing trolls so they are
up here in that area where it says
Femina Kyle's so you'll want to run
through here
run over here
open the gate run up here and
then they're all up here
okay someone's already here so I will go
ahead and
switch worlds or no wait no no one just
here my bed I don't even need this
energy plot so you don't need to bring
if you don't want to but come over here
I thought that was a cannon ball but
there's just people throwing rocks so
you want to set up your cannon around
here go ahead and start praying melee
and then set it up right here in that
general area
and
then fire cannon and then you're gonna
want to just attack whatever is
attacking you and then I will come back
I will start a timer now just to see how
long 3,000 cannonballs last and then we
will see how much xp I game all right we
just finished our first trip and I've
already got a room kite shield to ruin
warm hers and then some other items I'm
just gonna reap in town here in the bank
and then go back up there I the thing I
would suggest actually is bringing less
prayer pots and bringing more food I
didn't think that through I forgot that
they do actually get you pretty hard so
bring more food and then I'll put in my
pin but it's only been about seven
minutes so I'm just going to repack and
then go back up there alright there's
the second load we're at 22 minutes I
think the hour will probably happen
before my three thousand cannonballs so
if that happens then I'm just gonna stop
the video at an hour to check everything
but here's the second load I've been
picking up the atom in axes the steel
plate bodies and the raw sharks so just
real quick I'll show you guys kind of
what your inventory more wants to look
like now
so I need my spec weapon so you want it
to look more like this you want to have
a bunch of fish take about I mean even
five prayer pots is a little overkill
but and then just take one of each of
these and then
maybe take about five more so this is
kind of what your inventory wants to
look like because that way you're
getting where you're not watching your
monkfish or not wasting anything else so
this is actually what you want your
inventory to look like the first one I
had was wrong I thought they hit harder
but they're not hitting as hard as I
thought so anyways I'll be back when I
have another load all right my third
load and probably my best I got a room
kite shield the granite shield and ruin
our seats so I'm gonna go rehear and
then go back alright this is my next
load to room kite chill it's pretty nice
Oh
Beck all right there's the hour and I
just happened to run out right at the
right time so I'm gonna go ahead and go
to the bank go to the grand exchange and
then get out all the items that I got
and then show you guys the loot and
we'll do some calculations alright now
it's time to see how much money we made
alright so in one hour we made 459 kay
735 gp+ this long bone and then I
wouldn't head did some math so I made
that much money five hundred four
hundred fifty nine thousand seven
hundred thirty-five and then I minus the
411 k 826 GP that it cost that's the
cost of the pair pots the monkfish the
cannons and then that equals 47 K nine
hundred nine so that's how much money we
made in an hour I know doesn't sound
like a lot of money but you'll get a lot
of XP so I got 35 K meal exp and then
52,000 range XP very good method for
getting arranging speed while using a
cannon and also getting to me and exp
and it's very easy you can afk as long
as you just pick up the drops while
you're paying attention I hope you guys
liked this video I'm gonna be trying to
make a lot more videos this month so
stay tuned for that thanks for watching
guys stay tuned for my next video
[Music]